throughout the Marvel comic universes
decade of existence there are a slew of
heroes and villains who have vanished
without a trace from sidekicks to
psychos here are some of the MC use
characters who have disappeared without
explanation it may be easy to forget but
the Avengers weren't thor odin's son's
first super posse way back in his first
MCU film 2011 Thor Chris Hemsworth's
Asgardian rolled with a crew that
included lady SIF and the Warriors 3 I
do proved wrong after the idea that a
young maiden could be one of the
fiercest warriors this realm has ever
known I did
although Hogan Fandral and Volstagg all
perished at the hands of Heller in for
Ragnarok the whereabouts of Jaime
Alexander's lady SIF are still largely
unknown aside from a 2014 cameo on abc's
agents of shield the sword-swinging
warrior has been m.i.a in the MCU since
2013 Thor the dark world the Russo
brothers confirmed that she was indeed
one of the dusted casualties from Thanos
to snap in Avengers infinity war but
given that hoax snap and Avengers
endgame brought everyone back it's
entirely possible that the forgotten
Lady SIF is still out there somewhere
thus it turns out lady SIF wasn't the
only character to disappear after Thor
the dark world
Darcy Lewis who was played by two Broke
Girls kat dennings has been notably
missing in the MCU since 2013 as well so
- as her personal intern love interest
'i'm Boothby however dennings is
reprising her role for disney pluses 1
division but at this moments who knows
if we'll be seeing the real Darcy if we
know anything about scarlet witch's
penchant for creating alternate worlds
then perhaps this Darcy will be a
projection of Wanda Maximoff sis reality
altering abilities but if it is a real
Darcy
hopefully we'll figure out why she
disappeared for so long and where she's
been
it's the likely Darcy Orion will return
to the Marvel movies despite the fact
that their boss Jane Foster will be a
central figure in the upcoming Thor love
and thunder well Bruce banners awkward
romantic fling with Black Widow was one
of the most criticized relationships
throughout the entire MCU what about his
first love interest Liv Tyler's Betty
rust from 2008 seemed credible Hulk
in a cinematic universe that prides
itself on connecting all the dots the
lack of Betty Ross really stands out but
one she was the lover of one of the main
Avengers and establishing their
relationship ate up a good portion of
Hulk's first movie and her father as
general Thunderbolt Ross played by
William Hurt and for MCU films to date
with his fifth confirmed appearance
coming in Black Widow
well rumors are surfacing that Tyler
could return to play an important role
in Disney plusses upcoming she-hulk
series don't be surprised if Betty is
yet again left out of the fun although
he's on a core member of the Avengers
family stellan skarsgård stalked Erik
Selvig has been a pivotal figure in the
MCU ever since his introduction in
2011's Thor an einstein-rosen bridge is
a theoretical connection between two
different points of space wormhole the
noted astrophysicist not only played
large roles in both Thor and Thor the
dark world but he also popped up in both
the Avengers and Avengers age of Ultron
if you recall he's actually the
brainwashed brains behind creating
Loki's tesseract powerful portal during
the Battle of New York but where the
heck has he been since 2015 remember the
guy who Hank Pym punched in a man's
opening flashback scene who the heck was
he anyways you mentioned my wife again
and I'll show you ferocity as it turns
out Mitchell Carson played by weeds
Martin Donovan was actually kind of a
big deal in the MCU
he was once a head of defense at shield
which of course meant that he was
secretly a Hydra operative he'll Hydra
in the events of ant-man Carson tries
and fails to purchase a yellowjacket
armor from Darren cross making it out of
the building alive during the ensuing
chaos in fact he even manages to escape
with a briefcase full of crosses Pym
particles so where has he been since
surprisingly Carson hasn't been heard
from or even mentioned since he escaped
Pym technologies but there's no doubt
those Pym particles will show up again
somewhere the Marvel Universe has no
shortage of useful scientists Claudia
Kim's renowned geneticist dr. Helen Cho
who played a semi significant role in
Avengers age of Ultron was arguably one
of the top minds on the list her vast
knowledge proved invaluable to the
Avengers as evidenced by how quickly she
was able to heal Hawkeye after he was
injured early on in the film you'll be
made of you mr. Barton your own
girlfriend will be able to tell the day
well I have a girlfriend that I kept
fixed ultimately it was also her
regeneration cradle that inadvertently
created vision one of the most powerful
heroes and the Avengers lineup to date
as age of Ultron wrapped up show is
glimpsed alongside Maria Hill in the New
Avengers facility presumably a permanent
member of the team staff however dr. Cho
hasn't been heard from since
but given the importance of the Cho name
and hoax comic storylines we'll probably
see her again eventually Oh Trevor what
have you gotten yourself into now after
posing as the intimidating terrorist
leader Mandarin in Iron Man 3 Trevor
Slattery played by Sir Ben Kingsley is
loved up in seagate prison
Oh
that would have been the last we saw of
the goofy English doctor had not been
for 2014's or hail the king
which shows stuttery beam captured
broken out of jail and taken to meet the
real Mandarin the fact that there is
indeed a real Mandarin in the MCU was
headline news to fans of Marvel Comics
who recognize the Mandarin as Iron Man's
powerful archenemy it seemed as though
the real Mandarin would finally be
introduced when he met Trevor but
unfortunately it's a mean thing we might
not ever get to see sadly Trevor hasn't
been referenced since 2014 seemingly
lost in the chaos of the Infinity Saga
what it sounds like fans will finally
get to meet the real Mandarin in
Marvel's upcoming shang-chi chances are
that we've heard the last of Trevor
Slattery in the films anyway the
character has been referenced in the
webseries whi H news front where it was
revealed that in the world of the MCU
Hollywood Studios for turning Trevor's
story into two separate competing TV
movies it's impossible to the night at
2014's guardians of the galaxy packed a
star-studded cast there are actually two
oscar-nominated performers who is easy
to forget also popped up in guardians
Glenn Close and john c reilly clothes
played Nova prime while Reilly played
her right-hand man Roman day your mother
was of earth your father
well he's something very ancient we've
never seen here before well most of the
characters introducing guardians went on
to pop up in the future MCU installments
both Nova prime and Roman day were never
heard from again
it seems rather odd that these seemingly
significant characters are left on the
bench especially considering the
buddy-buddy relationship that Peter
quill and des had started to form in
Avengers infinity war photos reveals
that he destroyed Xander in order to
retrieve the Power Stone from the Nova
Corps so it can be assumed that both
Nova prime and day died to join the
events don't hold your breath for
another appearance from either one of
them unless a flashback reveals
something unpredictable in guardians 3
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]